[Musique]
je vous dis ce soir est un événement sur
s'est vite c'est bien sûr le spectacle
d'autres jean-luc personal en direct sur
s'est vite et je voulais demander à tous
de nous faire revivre de bons moments
avec jean luc lemoine et on va commencer
par mathieu alors c'est pas bon de vente
et parler de moi mais ça commençait mal
on est second tous les deux sur scène et
en rires et en chaume et ce qu'il a en
moins par rapport à moi c'est qu'il
bouge très très mal son corps et il a
habillé aussi à voir à quoi il est
habillé lui non non pas du tout
j'aimerais bien que ça aussi la moins il
bouge très très mal son corps et du coup
pas forcément heureux de revoir les
moments où ils dansent un petit peu vous
forcément il déteste ça est forcément
cyril le financer il est toujours hyper
gêné d'ammoniac à un bal et un peu ça
donne ce qu'il est un ballet un peu un
peu voilà brut alors que tu veux ou tu
veux on chausse les à côtés
[Applaudissements]
j'aimerais qu'on accueille quand même
tpiy dont
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les francos petit boost a bien aidé en
cela il est déguisé en fait ouais merci
qui oui mais dans celle étaient
déguisées ça va te fait l'émission
non on se calme on se détend mais il est
très très bon j'aime beaucoup je dis
merde pour ce soir et on lui dira tous
merde pour soir évidemment direct à 21h
matin heure 6 0 lille votre image
ouais une séquence ça montre vraiment le
talon de jean-luc on y voit tout ce
qu'on ne voit pas circle il a vraiment
un talent pour ça donc ça va concerner
isa isa qui dansent extrêmement bien
tout le monde le sait donc qui a vu sa
séquence on le sait mais c'est pas vrai
elle à son rythme à elle voilà ce temps
ses tempos mais là il a fait un petit
dérivé c'était plutôt d'or avec isabelle
regarder
[Musique]
je voterai n'avance pas je me rappelle
que c'était d'abord à une coupure et
ensuite j'avais ces 48 heures sans
dormir à cause du travail intel en
hauteur paco de travail mais bien sûr 1
qu'est ce qu'on fait pendant 48 heures
dans votre travail travail le matin
comme j'enchaîne et rtl est ici quand
une seule écoute et la belle isabelle
alors à la rivale déjà ouverte et elle
repart rt je parle non elle fait en
moyenne 6 à 8 minutes dopé par jour
[Applaudissements]
24 25 mai ne tente et on m'a tuer c'est
pas que pour deux fois pour sortir 50
secondes on peut y passer des fans
wiseman hérité d'un plan cul
[Applaudissements]
alors les plantes et ça prend que cinq
minutes beaucoup même pas savoir
alors moi ça concerne encore mathieu
c'est une question que j'aurais bien
aimé que tu me poses d'ailleurs avant de
l'embrasser en loge aménagée toucher
quoi je voulais parler du 4/3 ah oui oui
et non
direction je vais vous tuer - vous avez
perdu en fait là en fait j'ai eu une
séquence des cas tiers et puis j'ai vu
effectivement mathieu qui demandait à
jean-luc son style de mec est évidemment
allé voir sa réponse est frappante
en plus on s'entend bien avec mathieu
mêlée je dois vous avouer une chose je
crains qu'il ne soit volage
non si les voilages et amoureux de vous
mais quand vous vous absentez il va but
est d ailleurs
non mais nous tue quelque chose de
partir je pense que toi et moi
franchement
[Musique]
enfin vous essayez avec tout le monde
certains disent oui nous avons commandé
un rôle à moi qui me le propose l'office
pas de lui-même à la fin de l'émission
et hors antenne témoin à monsieur moreau
les carrières sont jean-michel mon
camarade mon bon fidèle ami qui n'est
pas là qu'on embrasse d'ailleurs qu'il
reviendra très vite et dans le milieu on
l'appelle de tarbes à jean mi parce que
dès que évidemment les caméras sont
coupées
croit-il il balance des vannes sur tout
le monde et il est très méchant avec
tout le monde on vous a fait un petit
florilège on regarde les bonnes photos
même chose en fait le à les y voilà
isabelle
[Applaudissements]
pour en finir avec le physique soyons
honnête et réaliste le plus beau de
l'équipe reste et restera à jamais et on
pense tous ces caisses qui ont faussé
aguerris et jean-michel par exemple
l'action qui va avoir un bon dos
[Musique]
et pourtant la loi
[Rires]
les
merci christophe carrière quel avenir
dans l'es4 pierre djian luxe et qui
montrent le vrai visage des gens
finalement alors rien alors déjà une
précision on va revoir aussi qui me
concerne dans pas longtemps
oui a toujours le vrai visage l'asie
barre haute et je rentre chez moi et je
rentre chez moi
d'ailleurs je viens de découvrir je
pense comme je décide que je fais ce que
je veux je pense que j'avais jamais je
vais passer ton tôt oui mettons que vous
soyez l'exception qui confirme la règle
bien sûr en tout cas je suis mon match
pour matthieu delormeau c'est la vérité
il est one très premier degré et
rappelons qu'il a travaillé à la sncf
mais on va comprendre en voyant les
images tu vas sncf est tu viens pas volé
un regard des réflexions inattendu et
franchement ça fait mon bonheur las je
pense que c'est ma vidéo préfet du mois
ont été regardées de niveau premier
degré c'est fabuleux
ghoulam angoulême 2 millions de da
réveillez vous éloigner de la bordure uk
le train desservira les gares de mouches
ville
pyros à égal au bandeau
[Applaudissements]
et
vous êtes bloqué de ma couleur de
cheveux j'ai vu bien de vous revoir la
vôtre en rouge
ouais non sadc dégueulasse rappeur
d'origine résine à régis chanteuse mary
j
jésus est en tout cas tu avais pas si la
brosse et désire maintenant chez
desireless voyage pour ceux qui n'ont
rien
[Applaudissements]
la coupe était comme un but un peu plus
alors je ne lève pas le bras je
m'explique pourquoi parce que ici dans
ce studio algérie ne jamais avoir trop
froid
en revanche moi je crève de sault et si
je lève les bras
c'est un quart de bezzaz donc je vais
présenter l'émission comme ça la clé des
bars voilà alors sur peuvent amener une
chemise avait même trouvé quoi amener
mois une chemise propre nicolas non
mettez-vous à torse nu rui taux retenu
[Applaudissements]
allez
donc la réponse est non gilles alors une
de mes séquences préférées les cas
tierces et touche pas mon bistrot c'est
quand jean-luc prono discussions ralenti
et qu'il en fait une séquence
extrêmement important qu'on est ivre
mort librement on avait refermé
moi je mets
[Musique]
tu sais pas quoi ils vous regardent les
deux et je regardes et tu mens faire
[Musique]
trouve que vous êtes méprisant pour la
france de la cour a jugé à s'exciter
présente pour la france qui travaille
parce que celles qui regardent le servir
rémy n'est qu'en fin sur pause elle a
pas forcément envie de se coucher à
23h05 parce qu'elles travaillent le
lendemain matin à lévis
c'est très très heureuse alors madame
madame mary jo ici oui bon ça met une
fois je trouve jean luc séduisant oui
oui oui du point mais je démontrais
numéro qui vous vous affairez roux et
jean luc
j'adore les roues mais jean luc lemoine
occupe une place à part
et julien courbet aussi et je voulais
combes et aux irakiens exams essaies tu
poses les trois jeux la courbe et
lemoine et un roux voilà en avoir ce
n'est pas ça dépend ça dépasse alors en
tout cas moi j'ai voulu revoir ses plans
j'ai voulu revoir ses débuts sur
téléphone où il était déjà extrêmement
beau selon mes critères
mais pas encore complètement abouti sur
le plan de la lure regardez
[Rires]
on m'apporte une dépêche de dano minutes
tiens papa merci renaud donc on apprend
que le repas est prêt je vais donc
devoir conclure cette édition en
précisant qu'elle sera avancée d'une
heure demain puisque je regarde le match
de foot voilà je vous souhaite une bonne
soirée et on quant à moi je leur
enseigne
[Applaudissements]
je rend l'antenne avec antenne dans la
main ça c'est drôle à tous les
fondamentaux sains
merci pour votre expertise et moi je
veux pas de votre
c'est public qui décide donc comme dit
christophe les cathares de jean-luc le
révèle le vrai visage
alors non c'était une blague parce qu'il
y avait mon père mon père il a un petit
côté loup de tex avery c'est vrai qu'il
a il a positionné il a il a fait comme
ça alors qu'on va le faire avec les
braves c'est pourquoi parce que là on
était comme ça et il est tombé sera
d'être leproux et là il a les yeux qui
lui sont sortis les en biseau remise
orbite sa langue natale à la longue ce
doute tout est sorti et il a vraiment
changé de tête à la mâchoire qui est
déjà assez proéminent qui est tombé
comme ça et il me dit c'est qui celle là
on peut peut-être voir l'image mais je
précise parce que moi j'ai des poèmes à
la maison
alors je désamorce le truc donc j'ai
fait un allin quolibets qui n'était pas
drôle du tout je m'en excuse auprès d'un
gâteux pro après j'ai des ans en ce
moment où la paix bon après je rentre
chez moi il faut que j'explique pourquoi
j'ai dit cette chose épouvantable que je
le dis d'ailleurs jamais ils ont cette
fois vous l'avais dit je n'ai dit pas ce
que je lis les boules c'est très drôle
parce qu'il bim bam la blague la banane
maintenant que j'ai donc chérie je ne le
pense pas ouais voilà on sait pas de la
radio elysée
non je vois la regarder ce qui se
justifie marqué ses limites et c'est
très mal de dire ça c'est pire de faire
ça deux générations de castel dit le
papa de benjamin découvrez agathe a
je suis
si la gemmi dit cette phrase moi tu ne
te dit pas tout il a déjà dit oui
[Musique]
le monteur en tout cas je m'excuse
c'était pour jouer dans la vérité si je
mens il le disait on elle dira elle vit
elle a les yeux qui sont plus menacés
pas mieux un ou moi c'est grâce à moi
c'est une référence à la mer voilà c'est
ça j'ai dit ouais ouais merci pour cet
avant qu'on passe aux images dès midi
puisque vous l'avez ramener on je
m'occupais de vodka alors effectivement
il ya les quatre tiers ça on le sait
mais jean luc est aussi excellent là à
sa place de sniper il a tout le temps
une bonne vanne à sortir et c'est
d'ailleurs la raison pour laquelle il
faut absolument vous alliez voir le
spectacle vous le regardez 60 sur ces
huit jeux les vues il est génial et donc
du coup avec les équipes qui ont bossé
d'arraché pied il on a fait une petite
compil de ses meilleurs puncheurs line
pas pareil quand vous dire que matthieu
delormeau me trouve très à son goût
c'est une bonne nouvelle pour moi ou pas
alors vous allez le voir il va arriver
dans un instant de las vegas ya beaucoup
changé ah bon viril
qu'est ce que vous en avez j'adore
j'adore me promener cuit ah oui ça ne
m'étonne pas d'avoir un gros succès je
suis désolé pour maman quand je
regardais l'époque à l'antenne c'était
vraiment pour moi la seule erreur
vraiment du casting certaines village
trouvé que j'étais arrivé
je vous rappelle ce soir c'est vite
21h56 évidemment jean luc lemoine en
direct à l'olympia